well whales is in the calm before the
storm
uh this week the delta variant continues
to be the dominant variant in wales
numbers are stable
hospital numbers slowly coming down
but we know that the omicron wave is
brewing
and that when it arrives in wales it
will rise very swiftly and very steeply
and so we're having to prepare for that
as well
so talk us through mr drakeford if you
would these tighter measures
well before christmas we will be issuing
new strong guidance to people in wales
as to how they can keep themselves and
others safe in the run-up to christmas
very simple things like if you are going
out to a gathering of any sort
make sure you've taken a lateral flow
test flow before you go as we tell
people in wales think about who you're
meeting
are you going to be meeting somebody who
is vulnerable because of their own
health and make that part of your plan
could you meet outdoors instead of
indoors are you doing all those simple
things the mask wearing the hand washing
the simple things we've learned to do
that help to keep one another safe
provided we all do that we think we can
get a run through to christmas where
people can enjoy christmas but stay safe
at christmas as
well immediately after the presidency
nightclubs to close from the 27th so
viruses don't wait for christmas why not
sooner
uh because as i say in the
days ahead up to christmas the delta
variant will be the dominant one here
in wales and the safeguards we have in
place the coveted paths you have to use
to go to a nightclub for example
we think that that will be sufficient to
keep whales safe but because we know
that the omicron variant is here already
and is guaranteed to grow
we need to take action after the
christmas break so nightclubs will not
reopen
when shops reopen then the rules will be
stricter
controls on the number of people
entering shops one-way systems
organized queuing at checkouts and so on
when offices reopen the two-meter rule
will be back as part of the reasonable
measures that have to be taken in wales
all of those things designed to shore up
our defenses
against the way we know is coming our
way
one of the problems that wales had in
previous lockdowns is that you would
impose restrictions and people would
just go across the border so what's
what's to stop people going doing their
nightclubbing their post-christmas
nightclubbing over in england
uh well you're right that the border is
very poor some people who live across
the border can make those choices uh
it's a very small fraction of the large
population uh that is in that position
and makes those decisions
we're seeing already not just in wales
but across the united kingdom
people making decisions in their own
lives to keep themselves safe and that's
what we will be appealing to people in
wales to do there is a big wave coming
our way
and unless we do the sensible things
lives that otherwise could be saved will
be lost
our health service will face an enormous
challenge we can all do things to help
and that's what people in wales i know
will want to do
i know you're urging people in wales to
have a smaller christmas to restrict the
number of people that they're mixing
with at the national level do you think
that that message is coming across
clearly
from prime minister boris johnson about
what he expects the people to do
well the uk government is now embarked
on a major advertising campaign and
their advertising campaign is in line
with our message to people in wales that
a smaller christmas is a safer
christmas this year
we know that that takes place against a
very difficult backdrop because of
everything that has gone on inside
downing street and inside the uk
government
despite all that
i hope that people across the united
kingdom will hear that message we are
all of us facing a very difficult
january
we can all help
to deal with that and i hope that the
messages that all governments across the
united kingdom are giving will be
listened to and will be acted upon
what do you make of the chief chief
medical officer coming under fire
according to reports and papers by many
tory mps for freelancing and for
frightening people for just suggesting
that they should prioritize their social
interactions is that responsible
uh it's not responsible
at all i think it is disgraceful that
the chief medical officer of england
should come
under attack uh in that way
uh the chief medical officer is giving
the best advice he can
from his depth of clinical knowledge and
understanding
it is very good advice indeed and i
think it is disgraceful that he should
be attacked and his message undermined
by people who have nothing like the
grasp that he has
of the omicron variant and it's likely
affecting the united kingdom uh i think
those people should think very carefully
about a period of silence on their part
first minister of wales mark drakeford
really good to talk to you